you
a man who spent three decades in prison
for a murder he says he did not commit
could be a big step closer to freedom as
soon as tomorrow
Crossley Greene was found guilty of
shooting and killing 22 year old chip
Flynn in 1989 prosecutors relied on the
word of Flynn's former girlfriend Kim
Halleck
even though law enforcement thought she
might be the shooter Erin Moriarty who's
followed this case since 1999 for 48
hours spoke with green ahead of the
federal appeals court hearing my name is
cross Nick green I've been convicted for
a crime I didn't commit
31 years that's nothing to break him in
that's enough to destroy a man in the
early morning hours of April 4th 1989 22
year-old Charles Flynn known as chip was
found in a Florida orange grove with a
single bullet in his chest
still alive Flynn's former girlfriend
Kim Halleck told police that a black man
had robbed a couple hijacked them and
then shot Flynn I don't believe a word
she says Brevard County first responders
mark rixie and Sergeant diane clark
questioned why Halleck didn't
immediately call 9-1-1 instead she drove
to a friend's house something's wrong
here something is not ringing true more
surprising was what happened when they
found Flynn lucid and talking first
words out of his mouth were get me out
of here
did he mention anything about an
assailant
don't know I'm thinking what the hell is
going on here
Flynn was pronounced dead at the
hospital Hallett was never investigated
as the possible shooter even though she
admitted she had argued with Flynn who
has seen another woman instead
detectives arrested 31 year-old Crosley
Greene a small-time local drug dealer
and charged him with kidnapping robbery
and murder it was a total shock this was
like picking a name out of a hat
Halleck who said she didn't get a good
look at the assailant
pick greens photo from what his
attorneys say was a rigged line up cross
a greens picture is put in what is known
in investigative circles as the bullseye
because it's where your eyes naturally
go to first rixie and Clark now retired
went to the assistant state attorney
handling the case
Christopher White and told him they
believe Kim Halleck was the shooter
white took notes I reviewed all the
evidence that we had with that
hypotheses in line he spoke about that
meeting in 2015 do they give me cause to
believe that Kim Halleck may have
committed this murder my answer is No
prosecutors built their case around
three witnesses including green sister
Sheila who testified the green it
confessed to them Green was offered a
deal but he turned it down
I can't plead guilty to something I
didn't do on September 5th 1990 an
all-white jury convicted green but since
then Sheila green and the other
witnesses have recanted Green got his
biggest break when his attorneys
obtained something Christopher white
never intended them to see those notes
from the meeting with Mark Richt C and
Diane Clark mark and Diane suspect the
girl did it she changed her story a
couple of times also noticed she never
asked how the victim was in July 2018 a
federal judge ruled that withholding
those notes from Crosley green kept him
from getting a fair trial and he
reversed his conviction our Constitution
prohibits the government from hiding
evidence of innocence and that's what
happened here and yet because the state
of Florida is appealing Green is still
in prison
I want the truth to come out okay you
choose to this case is that I've been
locked up all these years for a crime I
didn't commit
hopefully I get that chance to go home
that's the truth
the Florida Attorney General's Office
says that it's unable to comment on this
pending case but in a brief filed last
year it called the federal courts
decision to reverse greens conviction
procedurally factually and legally
incorrect we've also reached out to Kim
Halleck in the former assistant state
attorney Christopher white who have not
responded to our request for comment I
would love to sit down with Kim Halleck
she has never spoken to me and I all she
has to do is kind of explain what
happened where is she now
she is living in titusville going on
with her life while of course right now
Carla Green is sitting in prison now
he's gonna get closer I think to having
a real decision here tomorrow morning
and I'll be there the federal appellate
court will hear oral arguments and if
the court rules in his favor
then he either has to get a new trial
within 60-90 days they'll have to decide
or let him go home Wow right we hope
justice will be served